hi I'm Eric Foss and Avengers infinity
war is now out on digital age Steve with
some deleted scenes including one
alternate version of the heart to heart
between Thanos and Gamora that actually
reveals big implications for Avengers 4
I'm gonna walk you through the scene and
explain why it's the most important
thing in your life forever and ever
spoiler warning in case I'm actually
right in let's dive in the planet has
been taken father the third I came fudge
is eternal loyalty to your cause
[Music]
okay this deleted scene is an extended
version of that scene midway through
infinity war after Thanos takes Kimora
and before she takes him to Vermeer to
get the soul stone the two are in the
throne room of Thanos his sanctuary ship
except in this version we initially see
younger versions of themselves as we'll
see in a second this is a memory that
Thanos is watching from a time when
Gamora still served him as a child of
Thanos helping him conquer various
civilizations across the universe here's
she just finished conquering the third
eye king who by the way does not appear
to be any known character from Marvel
Comics and no he is not Stephan Jenkins
with their right blind they're a
democracy not a monarchy Morris is a
third a king pledged his eternal loyalty
to Thanos his cause which turns out to
be a dark joke when she plops the king
severed head in front of Thanos implying
that he did not bend the knee after all
still as his crown on top and yes by the
way all the effects here are still
unfinished as is the case with pretty
much all deleted scenes which get
removed earlier in the post-production
process so you know there's no point to
polishing the VFX it seems like a
no-brainer thing to explain but you
would be surprised let's keep watching
by the look of it you seem content
enough at the time the prisoner
so yes this red blue here is Thanos
using the reality stone to project this
memory like a nostalgic Papa watching a
home movie from before his little girl
made him drop her off a block away from
school we see fantasies the reality
stone similarly in the final cut
remember when he projected the Utopia
that his homeworld Titan used to be to
explain his agenda to dr. strange now if
you think about this the reality stone
doesn't necessarily project reality as
it truthfully was like I think you can
make it whatever you want it to be so
this memory right here may be filtered
by Dennis's biased point of view let's
move on after my planet died I had
nothing no one when I thought I never
would I was alright with that I had a
new vocation then I found you been at my
side you became the fiercest woman in
the galaxy okay one main element that
the scene would have brought the final
cut was a bit more humanity from Thanos
like we would get a sense of why Gamora
means so much to him on an emotional
level and why it was so painful for him
to sacrifice her now ultimately I think
we still got a very good sense of that
throughout the movie like the flashback
of dannis giving her the dagger when
she's a girl and Thanos's single-tier
moment at her death plus the final
version of the scene goes a lot deeper
into Thanos's logical rationale so I see
why this version might have been seen as
exposing next that's why I chose you to
find the soul stone I'm sorry I
disappointed you I am disappointed
not because you didn't find it because
you lie okay so we saw these exact words
exchanged in the final cut which from a
story perspective is the key reveal
because we now know gomorrah knows where
the final infinity stone is actually if
you watch the VFX breakdown footage with
josh brolin in this mocap suit you
really get a sense of how powerful his
acting is in this moment his voice is
Stannis really underlines the terror
Gamora must feel at this revelation
moving on that's why when you left me
all those years ago I allowed it you
allowed it under the impression you
escaped you didn't raise me you
kidnapped me or offend me and imprison
me everything I hate about myself comes
from you heareth and this is referring
back to when Gamora joined the guardians
of the galaxy in that first movie he
initially tasked her with retrieving the
Power Stone but she later betrayed
Thanos and join forces with the
guardians now at the time it seemed as
though she made that choice on her own
but now that they honest is suggesting
he allowed it to happen perhaps he felt
that she would be more successful at
finding the rest of the stones if she
felt that she wasn't working for him and
then in reality he was just following
her tracks also in this lead diversion
Gamora screams at Thanos compared to the
way he's always Saldana delivers the
line in the final cut so I suppose
gamora's words themselves are really
aggressive enough in saying them would
require a nerve that might make her feel
a little nervous and on to the final
part at one point out you had a family
here in any one
yes you just didn't care what happened
to it okay so the deleted version of the
scene ends with Banias using the space
stone to teleport the two of them into
the torture room with nebula as opposed
to them just going through a door in the
final version but really it's this
emotional moment between father and
adopted daughter that hides the deeper
meaning over these months we've been
speculating what could bring Thanos down
and Avengers for the directors the Russo
brothers has suggested a different kind
of attack would be needed against a
threat like pianos and rewatch an
infinity war the thing that hurt him
more than anything was definitely the
death of Gamora
that put him at his weakest state so
could Gamora be the hero to defeat
Thanos ain't she dead though well the
Russos shed more light on that too
confirming that Gamora still exists
inside the soul stone and the way
Thinnes used the reality stone in the
scene reminded me a lot of another
weapon we've seen before in the MCU the
one Tony Stark shows off at the
beginning of Captain America Civil War
by narrowly augmented retro framing a
ka-bar sure it's not like the weapons he
showcased at the beginning of Iron Man
and Iron Man 2 but the ability to create
lifelike projections to relive core
emotional memories is absolutely
something that could be used against
Thanos especially if the ghost of Gamora
proves to be his main vulnerability I
know that in civil war barf was
introduced as a way to remind us of
Tony's fraught relationship with his
parents which he never settled because
the Winter Soldier killed him which
created the wedge between him and cap
but as a narrative device barf is so
much more useful than that barf could be
something that affects everyone with
powerful forces bubbling deep inside us
we need just to be laugh comment down
below with your thoughts on this theory
and tweet me directly at a bus and
follow me rock stars on Twitter for
updates under videos like this video
shoot around and subscribe to new rock
stars for all the big Avengers theories
and MCU updates that you need to know
about thanks for watching and remember
kids if someone asks you how to beat
Thanos its barf pie
[Music]